ich Gründe ein Startup und trotz meiner
Reichweite habe ich mich sofort gegen
ein Produkt für den Supermarkt
entschieden obwohl es riesige Vorteile
hat Vorteil 1 Getränke Chips Pizza sind
consonsumables man braucht sie auf und
kauft sie dann eben wieder neu und
bedeutet immer und immer wieder auch
mehr Umsatz Vorteil 2we das Regal im
Supermarkt ist eine viel größere
werbeflächer als jede Reichweite von
irgendeinem Creator in Deutschland für
mich überwiegen die Nachteile aber
definitiv gerade wenn man das so wie ich
mit einem kleinen Team selber umsetzen
will und vielleicht sogar Ambitionen hat
irgendwas international zu reißen schon
in Deutschland ist der Einzelhandel mega
undurchsichtig manche Sachen werden auf
Bezirksebene geregelt manche pro Markt
und manche von ganz oben aus einem
Headquarter dann dürfen nicht alle
Inhaltsstoffe in allen Produkten
weltweit einfach so benutzt das ist der
Grund warum Fanta in Frankreich oder den
USA eben anders schmeckt als in
Deutschland und natürlich unheimlich
hohe Entwicklungs lagerungs Produktions
und Logistikkosten außerdem was habe ich
damit zu tun was ihr esst oder trinkt
ich habe keinen fitnesskanal der es
nahlegen würde irgendein Fitnessgetränk
zu produzieren und auch kein kochkanal
der es nahlegen würde irgendeine Speise
zu produzieren um herauszufinden wie ich
am Ende trotzdem die perfekte Idee für
mich gefunden habe klickt auf dieses
Video